一般的な世界 普通の日常的な生き方で
例えば一日取ってみる
二十四時間 二十四時間の間で
大ざっぱでもいいんだけど
自分が物事を観察的に見る時と
主観的に見る時と とか
どうせ人間だからいつでも客観的に見るということはないでしょうし
すぐスイスイ主観的になるということもあるし
例えば自分持っている固定概念がありますね
固定概念というか ほとんど貪瞋痴ですからね
怒りか欲ですね で そういう自分の感情で判断して見る時と
そうでなくて まあありのままに見る時と
一応二十四時間の中でどれぐらいかと自分で見てみれば
ああ これぐらいはヴィパッサナーから注意が生まれているんだということなんです
でも それはなかなか本人にはできないんですけど
自分が実験台になって自分を実験することはね
そういうことでもう他人が言って観察しておかないとね
他人から注意ないと 正しく他人に注意されているんだったら
多分それだけの原因で人が悟られるんです
人間っていうのはすぐ主観的に陥っちゃうんです
本人にはそれわからない
自分が好きな人がいるんだったら
その人の型を取って判断したり行動したりする
その人が何か間違い起こしたってても
まあだからといってそれはいいんじゃないんですかって
それを正当化しようとしちゃう
あるいはそれを隠そうとする
そこで第三者がいるんだったら
注意する人がいるんだったら
そこはそれはいけませんと
あんた主観的に見ているんだと言ってくれると自分に気づくでしょうに
ですから この心っていうのはいつでも主観的なものだから
あの 誰かがいい朋友がいて注意するんだったら
もうそれだけの原因で悟ることは可能なんです
そういうわけで また経典にちょっと戻りますけど
アーナンダ尊者が修行は悟ることの道
朋友がいれば半分できますよ
半分なんて五十パーセントで成功しますよと言ったんです
そこでアーナンダ尊者がもう大変
あの 何と言いますか 真面目に言うつもりなんです
なぜかというと 修行っていうのは自分でやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
本人が だから本人の権利を
本人やらなくちゃいけないというところは否定できませんし
ですから アーナンダ尊者がよく考えて
それでも教えてくれる人が厳しく戒める人がいるんだったら
結構うまくいくんだから
半分ぐらいはいくでしょうねと
で そこはお釈迦様に報告する
お釈迦様はアーナンダ尊者にはサーリプッタ尊者みたいに厳密に知識的にぶん殴るということはないんです
アーナンダ尊者はまだ第一番目に来たかつていませんでしたし
そこでお釈迦様の身の回りの世話しているんだから
で すごい親切にしてあげないと
そこで言ったのは いいじゃいますよ
いい朋友がいれば 朋友がいれば完成しますよ
完成しますよ 修行は というふうにお釈迦様は言ってあげるんです
その瞬間にアーナンダ尊者がそれを分かったかどうかね
もうわかりませんだけど
まあお釈迦様がおっしゃったことだから
はい わかりましたということには当然なるし
でもそれどういう意味かというと
やっぱり心っていうのはいつでも主観的になる
主観的になるようにプログラムできているんです
心に感情がいっぱいあるんだから
感情は我々の所動なんです
好きだからやるでしょうに
嫌だからやってるでしょうに
物事は 嫌だから反対する
何か嫌だから社会復讐をする
あるいは好きだからだ
どっちかなんですよ というわけで
生きる人々の所動は感情なんですから
ヴィパッサナーの世界じゃないんです
客観的な主観というのは
これ稀な人に 稀な天才にしかできないものなんです
大したことじゃないんですよ
真実は単純なんです 本当のところは
ただ単に感情に抑えられてできないだけ
そこでもし頑張って頑張って
この鳥の鶯の声でよかった
感動しましたということじゃなくて
感動しました 次に車のクラクションの聞こえた
驚びっくりしました 次にカラスがキャーッと鳴くのを聞いて怖くなった
そうやって観察していくんです
そこは客観的なんです
もしそうやってみて 何の味もないかもしれませんよ
味はこの感情の世界だから気持ちよかった
気持ちよかったっていう
そこでやがて自分が何かこの全部この味の世界消えてしまって
塩もお醤油もない人生になって
ただこう見ているんだ
何かあって 大変な損をしても
大変な得をしたって ああそういうことっていうことで
こう見れるんだったら
もうサッマッサナニャーナが智慧がついてるんです
そこはヴィパッサナーの成長なんです
ですから ヴィパッサナーの成長に
あの 何と言いますか いろいろあなたはこの第一段ですか
もう第二段 柔道第三段になったことは心よりおと証明いたしますとかね
そういうのはヴィパッサナーでは難しいんですけど
あの いろいろ免許を出すのは
あの で そこのポイントで出してるんですね
出す場合は サッマッサナニャーナ
観察能力ついてるかないかと
どれぐらいついてるかないか
それ完全に付いてないと次のステージにはいかないんです
でも悟りには四段階ありますから
一時的でいいんです 一時的でも完璧に観察能力
客観的に観察する能力がついちゃったら
次のステージに行っちゃうんです
二番目の智慧はウデヤックテニャーナ
これは消滅智というんですね
これ今説明しちゃうとおかしくなるんじゃないかな
あ これまた出てくるかな
出てこないね 消滅智っていうのはどういうことかというと
このもし感-完全に客観的に見ようとしちゃうと評価できなくなっちゃうんですね
ブッダの声が感動しましたとかね
なんと美しい声かとかね
評価できなくなっちゃうんです
できなくなって ああ いい気持ちが生まれた
それで次に ああ それ消えちゃった
次に何とか生まれた 次にそれ消えた
次の現象であれ 前のもの消えちゃって
新しい感情が生まれた
次のことでこうなったとか
座って瞑想の途中でブッダの声聞いちゃったら
さっと気持ちよくなったと
そこに惹かれたんだと
それを観察して 次にもう足が痛いんだと
その痛みを観察しちゃうと
感動しましたではなくて
まあ嫌ですよっていう気持ちがそこにあるんだと
それでも他のところに興味行っちゃうと
またその感覚が消えちゃって
また違うものや そうやって現れては消えて
現れては消え まあそのむちゃくちゃ物事は現れては消えて
現れては消えて 現れては消えて
現れては消えると もの落ち着きなくなくなるぐらいなんですね
まあ嫌だと もう観察さえも
そう思ったら主観的になっちゃいますけど
やりきれないんだと もう落ち着かなくなっちゃいますけども
現れてそれ現れて俺消えて
また次のこと現れて またそれ観察しようと思っちゃうと
またそこまた消えちゃって
またこれ現れて また観察するとまたそれも消えちゃうと
なんかすごい大変な状態にはなるんですね
その場合は瞑想の世界
サマーディの世界からは集中力はすごくできているんです
でも集中力できると気持ちいいはずなんですけど
この場合は集中力できると見えすぎなんです
感じすぎなんです 敏感に
あれも感じて これも感じて
あれもでも観察しようと思うと
もうとっくに消えてる
もうあれ観察しようと
もう消えてる という風に
ものすごい勢いで物事は現れては消えてるということは
そこで本人がラベリングしなくちゃいけないんだから
まあどうしようもなくなっちゃって
もう現れては消えてるんです
もうラベリングする暇もないほど出てくるんじゃないかなということに気づくんですね
そういう風にこの現れては消えていくんだという経験を得られるんですね
発見が現れます そこは二番目の智慧
次にバンガナーナという何て言いますか
壊滅知が生まれるんですね
これはね 私はもっと厳密な論理的なことを言いたくはなりますけど
まあ一応 まあとにかくバンガナーナという壊滅知という言葉に入れて
次の智慧が行っているんです
で 物事はもう確認できない
ラベリングできないほど
できないほどじゃなくて
もうものすごい勢いで
現れては消えて 現れては消えて
現れては消えているということで
ものすごく必死になってしまっちゃうし
もうどうしようもない状態にもなってくると
大体その場合は人がどんな人間でも
なんていうのか 諦めちゃうんですね
放っておくっちゃうんというかね
そこで消えていくことだけ見ているんですね
本当はもうラベリングとかなんとかできない状態なんです
すっごくこのもう 落ち着かない状態なんですね
落ち着かないって言っても悪い意味で落ち着かないではなくて
あまりにも見えすぎて
あまりにも心が客観的すぎて
まるっきり主観がなくなってしまって
もう抜群に頭が冴えているんですね
だから全部見えてるんです
今までやってきたサマーディ的なヴィパッサナーでも
最初はサマーディ的だから
サマーディ的やり方なんかこんなもうやれることはないんです
それで大体私たちは あのほんのちょっとどこかに気が付けた人
すぐそれ消そうとしますね
それ 家が 家の気が付いたところで
すぐ消そうとする 消そうとしてももうなかなか消せないと
消防車でも消防士でも呼んで消してもらおうと思う
消防車が来るともうどうしようもないんですね
その場合は そこで何やるかというと
放っておくんです もう
全部もうどうぞ燃やし
燃やし 燃やししまえ その代わりに周り
周りにはいかないようにと消防士そういうことなんですね
これはもう諦めたと もうそのままもう
全部もう燃やしてしまえ
諦めてもう周りに水をかけていろいろなことをして
周りに火の玉が飛べないようにするでしょう
で そこはある論理的な
立場なんですね で なんとなくこれ世の中ではね
もう そんないい例は浮かばないね
よくあることなんです
そういうことはもう 例えば家に何かもう何か機械があるとする
で 料理作ろうとして 電気レンジだとしましょう
で 買った時はすごい高かったんだから
すごく威張ったりもします
昔買ったものだったらね
かなり 10万以上でしたから
今は 2万  3万円ですけど
で これすごく大事に 威張りながら使っていると
でも 10万  15万になったっても
もう本当に機能が最低悪いんです
昔のものっていうのは
で みんなこの研究途中で品物を作って出しちゃいますからね
そこでいろいろトラブルあって
あれどうなったんですかとかね
またいろいろ修理したりして
それ使ってはいます そこでタイマーつけても時々つなげないとかね
そこで叩いたりしたりして
で いろんな工夫して工夫して
そこで何かちょっとどこか壊れたりする
そこは何かボンドで貼っておいたりとか
やっていて やっていて
とにかく直そう直そうとしている
そこである時期になってくると
一応タイマー入れる でも途中で止まる
また叩く また途中で止まる
またやる また止まると
もうやりきれなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで嫌いになっちゃうんですね
もう嫌だと もう全部捨てましょう
買った時は 15万円でしたけど
どうしようもない もう使えないんだ
もう一応捨てましょうと
もう新しいものを買うお金なくたってでももう嫌ですよ
ということになって捨てる気持ちになりますね
その捨てる気持ちになる前に捨てるために覚悟
しなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 悪いとこだけ見るんですね
その場合は 家 例えば引っ越しする時でもいっぱいゴミ溜まっちゃうでしょうね
全然捨てません 袋やらビニール袋からもうなんだかんだ一応しまってわけしまってわけしまっちゃうと
そこで整理しようと思ったらなかなか整理できませんよ
この書き入れちゃうと
それで困ってて もうとにかく整理しなくちゃいけないということになったら
本当はこれ大事ですよと思って置いたものですけど
まあ別にどうったことない
これも別にどうったことない
これもどうったことないということで
全部まとめてゴミにしてゴミにしてゴミにしていくでしょうに
その捨てる以前 そうやって
やっぱりまあいいや どんなことどうったことないやと決めなくちゃいけない精神的なレベルがあるんですね
その精神的なレベルなんですね
現れては消えて 現れて見られなくなっちゃう
そこで楽にマハって消えていくと
これもすぐ消えるんだと
これもすぐ消えるんだ
これもすぐ消えるんだっていうことを自動的にそこだけ見えるようになっちゃうんだ
消えるんだ 消えるんだっていうことを見えないと
あれ前にあったこの落ち着かない状態
いくらか落ち着くんです
通ってくるんです 例えば物を大事に大事にしまっておくことも気持ちいいでしょ
かえって取ってはゴミに捨てる
取ってはゴミに捨てる
それも気持ちいいんじゃないんですか？私は
私も気持ちいいんだけど
皆様どうか分かりませんけど
あ これこれもゴミだから
あ これもゴミだから捨てましょう
それでどんどんゴミ袋が大きくなっちゃうと気持ちいいんですね
そこは一つの見方なんですね
あ これはいいものだ これ大事にちゃんと整理しておきましょうということも気持ちいいんですね
こうやって全て私の八十年間の人生は全部綺麗に整理しているんだとかね
そうやって物を持つこと感じて
人々は気持ちいいと感じる場合もあって
じゃあ捨てちゃいましょう
これこれも捨てちゃいましょうと
そうやって捨てる時も気持ちいい場合もあります
だから私の場合は捨てた気持ちに捨てた
あれをしっかりしましたという気持ちは長持ちするんだけど
何か買ってきて買いたくて買いたくて買いますけど
買って部屋に持って行くところまではいいだけど
開けようともしない 一日
二日 三日 四日 一週間経ったところでは開けてみようかな
でも捨てる場合はすぐ捨てちゃいますけど
捨てたんだ しっかりしましたと
長持ちするんです その気持ちは
楽しい気持ちは 最近何か電気ひざ買いましたからね
二日目に諦めたんです
開けちゃった すごい研究して探検して買ったもんで
ものすごい研究して 買おう買おうと思ってもまあ何ヶ月かは経ったんです
まあ決めたんだから買いますと
そこで一回じゃあ買いますとお店に行って
やっぱりやめますと して
もっと調べなくちゃということで
それでこの買う このお店で買うんだと思った店にも三回ぐらい行ったんですね
他の店に何回行ったかということはね
私も覚えていないので
まあいろいろ調べるんで
とにかく 調べるの機能ばっかりなんですけど
そこで買ってきて まあ今それ繋げなきゃ繋げないと
これいつやるかわからないということで開けて繋げたんだけど
いろいろ苦労して苦労して繋げて
トラブルいっぱい出てきて
そこで考えて こうやってどうやってこのトラブル解決するんですかと
お風呂に入っても考えちゃったんですね
ものすごいトラブルがあって
これどうやって解決するでしょうと
そこでお風呂から出てくると
十二時過ぎて十五分 十二時十五分ぐらいでしたけどね
やっぱりこの方法でやっちゃえばいいんじゃないかなと
またもう初めからやり直しで
で まあ一時半 二時半までやって
あ  OK を踏んだ それで使い方見たら
あ 嫌だ なんでそんなもんかと
まあ次の日はもう開けました
開けちゃった だからもう心っていうのはそんなもんで
ものすごい瞬時に変化するもので
だからもし捨てたならば
捨てた気持ちは長持ちするんです
だから得た気持ちはすぐもう終わってしまっちゃうんです
で そこでヴィパッサナーの世界では
このできるだけヴィパッサナーの世界
私は日常生活の世界で説明したいんです
ヴィパッサナーの世界
もうごく普通の日常生活の体で
そうやって私たちもよくあるんでしょうし
諦めたと もう手の施しようも何もないんだと
と決めたところで ものすごく気持ちいい
例えば たとえ自分の親しい人がもう寝たきりになって看病していたっても
もうもうダメやと 何やっても
死ぬ瞬間まで待つ時間ないんだと思ったら心がいくらか落ち着くんです
そこでまあ人間としてはなんとなく人間まあ自偏だから
死んでよかったと思いたくないんだけど
本当はこれでよかったと思っちゃうんです
たとえもう命ほど大事な人であろうともね
だからそういう機能なんですね
もう手の施しようもないんだと
もうどうしようもない
本当は欲しいんだけど
いてほしいんだけど 元気になってほしいんだけど
もうどうしようもないと
だったら消えちゃったり
消えてほしい だからこの人の場合はね
まあ一生懸命もう看病して看病して
何もかもやってしまって
結局もう疲れ果てて道もない
明るさもまるっきり見えない
もう分かりきったことで
もうとにかく死ぬんだと
それでもかすかな希望があると本当に苦しいんです
もう生きていられないんですね
この看病する側が そこで本当には思ったりもしないんだけど
心のどこかにあるんですね
まあ早く消えた方がいいんじゃないか
それは自分のために思うんだけど
そこで逆に言うんですね
やっぱりこの人はね こんなに苦しんでるんだから
やっぱり延命措置なんかしてちゃってね
本人も苦しいでしょうとか
本人知らないんですけどね
苦しい 意識さえもないんだからね
こんなに我々の人間勝手に苦労させていいんですか？我々のわがままな希望でとかね
だから本人のためですから
延命措置をもうさせましょうと
そう思っちゃうでしょ
ですから そこら辺はまあ人間はまあ誰でもまあそんなもんですから
そこを別に非難する必要はないんですけど
だから気持ちはすごく複雑ですからね
心理言うとそんな気持ちじゃないでしょ
それだったら何年もかけて勘定する必要はないでしょうね
無理しちゃえば早く死んじゃいますからね
例えば心臓発作でも起こって倒れてると
まあいいや ちょっと後でお茶一杯でも飲んで煎餅も食べてから救急車呼びますったら死んじゃうでしょう
でもその時はもう全部やめて
すぐもう全部やってあげたんだから死んでほしいっていう気持ちはないんですけど
もうやりきれない状態になったら
やっぱり消えてしまえと
そこで楽を感じちゃうんですね
そこで物事は生まれては消えてく
生まれてるは消えてくというところで
その楽しさをこの死んでしまえと消えてしまえという
その楽しみをものすごく感じちゃうんです
楽しいっていうことじゃない
ものすごい複雑ですけど
これは自分の大事な人が人の延命措置発動ぐらいのものなんです
だからこれを人間の言葉で
瞑想の世界で言ったような
大変幸福ですよと 幸せ感味わえますよということじゃないんです
すごいすごい厳しい世界なんです
楽しいか苦しいかと どっちも言いにくいんだけど
とにかく智慧だけは生まれてくるんですね
消えてくんだ 消えてくんだ
消えてくんだ まあどうせ壊れるものなんです
それはヴァーガーナというんですね
壊滅ですか 全てのもののこの壊滅している状態は見てるわけです
そう見なきゃ 本人にはもういてもたってもいられない精神状態なんです
ヴァーガーナの次にあるのは何でした？これは憑依
不一 不一なんです それもこの言葉は日常生活の経験からつけてるんです
ですからこのあの 私はすごいレベル低く喋ってるんだからね
レベル低く考えていただいたらいいんです
とりあえず今の時間だけでも
後でどんなレベル高く考えたって構いませんんだけど
物事は消えていくと必ず出てくるのは何でしょうかね
怖いっていうことなんですね
じゃあレベル低く考えてみましょう
例えばこのあの東京の水道にいっぱいあのO157が入ったんだと
感染する人々いっぱいいるんだと
あの今もなんか新しいサルモネラ菌が出ているでしょうね
あれ乾燥したってもしない
かなり抵抗力あるんだ
で いろんな乾物にはもうもう入ってるんだ
ということを仮定しましょう
次の気持ちは ああ 良かったっていうことですかね
怖いでしょうに 水道開けて水飲めないでしょうに
そこで豊島区の水は大丈夫です
って言ったっても信頼しますか？東京都の水道はもうサルモネラじゃなくて
なんとかO157でもう大変汚染されているんだと
言ったら でも豊島区は大丈夫や
誰が知ってるんですか？豊島区にしたって
豊島区だけにきちんと水道引いてるわけじゃなくて
この水道の局が自分たちの質があって
それなりに水道を引いてるんだから
これわからないでしょうね
ただ 政治的に決まってる通りに線引いてるわけじゃないでしょうに
だってね そういうことでしょう
だから心配で心配で怖いんですね
だから物は消えていくんだ
消えていくんだ もう壊れるんだ
壊れるんだ これも壊れる
これも壊れる あれも壊れると
これ一番これ強烈なんです
この感覚って なぜならばヴィパッサナー瞑想自分のことを瞑想してるんだからね
そこを忘れないでください
このマンドラを瞑想してるわけじゃないんです
大日如来の大曼荼羅瞑想しているわけじゃないんです
カ la チャクラ曼荼羅を瞑想しているわけじゃないんです
自分のことをやってるわけです
だから自分のことはクオリティとクオリティとクオリティ
泡のように自分がはじけていくんではじけていく時
感じたらそれでどうなるんですかね
すっごい怖いんですね
そこはこの私の例えはあまりうまくいかなかったんですね
瞑想しているんだからそこら辺よくわかるはずなんですよね
で お釈迦様がこの自分の知恵をね
まあちょっと使って人をからかった時もあります
このコーサラ王様がある犯罪者をね
犯罪者ですか 処刑にして
その処刑最終的な決断をするために王様が出かけたんです
宮殿で人を処刑するわけにいきませんだから
それを遠く離れたところでやるんです
そこでもしかすると犯罪者のグループでしたかもしれませんし
そしたらこの勝手に処刑しないといったら
賄賂 インドの道徳の一つは賄賂ですからね
今でもそうなんで 何かやってほしければ
ゴールド一トンでもあげないとやってくれないんです
で だから当時でもそこはよくあったんです
その処刑に決めた人にしたっても
その処刑執行人たちが遠くする場所まで連れて行く
そこに誰もあまり人がいないんですね
誰でも人を殺すのは見たいものじゃないんだから
で そこでちょっとお金もらって
その人と逃がしてあげなさいって言ったら
またじゃあ逃げなさいと逃がしてあげて
別に王様に人の首とか死んだ体を持っていくわけにいきませんだからね
で 処刑実行いたしましたと報告するんです
そういうこともあり得るんです
だからグループの場合は
どうもわからないんですね
だからおそらく王様が自分で行ったんですね
行って人をここにきて
じゃあ実行しなさいと
王が自分の家を出るということは大変な仕事です
簡単じゃないんですね
王であろうか 総理大臣であろうか
出るということは大変でしょうし
日本にしたっても 天皇陛下がどこかに出かけるということは大変なことですよね
そこら辺ものすごい厳しいでしょうしね
警備やらどうだとか もし出かけたら
ついでにいろんなところに出かけるでしょ
あるどこかに天皇陛下出かけるなということがあったら
ついでに じゃあそこは 2時 から 3時 までだったら
もう何かどこかで何かのお祭り用意してて
じゃあ二時半から三時までそちらに来てくださいということに
まあ一応人前にそういう計画を立てられるんですね
それでせっかく出かけるんだから
まあ食事はなんとかなんとかとこだから
やっぱり朝三十分ぐらいなんとかどこかで来てほしいと
食事さんにも何か用意しちゃうと
そこで一旦出かけるのは大変なんですよ
出かけたら午前九時半九時から十時までどこかでなんかに参加してとかね
で 十一時から十二時までなんかどこかで参加するとか
そこでどこかに行って食事をするとか
そこでまたどこかに行ってなんとかして
どこか行ってなんとかして
そこで夜どこか泊まって次の日帰りましたという風なスケジュールなんですね
だからすごい忙しい 厳密なスケジュールになってしまうんですね
で 偉い方々の場合は 大体昔も今もそういう風になっちゃうんですね
だから人が電話して来て
じゃあ明日行きますよということにはならないんです
二年前にあるいは三年前に行って
宮内庁やらいろいろあるでしょうし
わかりませんだけどね
そちらに行って話し合って
いろいろいろいろ考えなければいけない
でもそれはその王様がこうする王様が出かけたんです
出かけたら王様考えたのは水路にお釈迦様のところに行きますよ
水路だから簡単ですね
そこでこの仕事は昼午前中なんですね
そこでそのまあまあ昼過ぎでしたけど
すごい暑いし 大体人に会う時間ではないんです
お釈迦様のところに行くんですね
王様もかなり疲れて汗ばっかしです
見定めて でお釈迦様はなんかじゃあね
あんたなんでこんな時間に来たんですか
そしたら私たちにはね
そういう忙しくてね なかなかお釈迦様に会って話をする時間がないんだと
だからまあそういう風になってきたんだ
という話でしたけど じゃあお釈迦様もうからかっちゃう
じゃああんたね 忙しくてね
何かいいことをする時間でもあり
暇でもありますけど お釈迦様お釈迦様は知ってるんですね
こいつは何をやってこちらに来たんですから
こういうところに来てるんだっていうことは知ってるんですけど
聖人だから王だからね
そこはもうどうすることもできませんし
急遽かが口出すとこじゃないんですね
あんたにいいことする暇もありますかと
そしたら はぁ 我々はね
そんなにでそんな暇がないんだと
お釈迦様 じゃあたとえ言いますと
もしあなたがね 大工仕事やってるところで人が出ていて
北の方から王様 大きな山が転がってくるんだと
全ての家やら建物やら人間やら動物やら植物やら全部潰されてるんだと
一人の命も残りませんと
こちらの方にも転がってくるんですということ
それでもう一人の人が走ってきて
南の方からすごい山を一つ転がしてくる
また同じ状況です もう一人の人がまた北の方からまた一つ山が
植物も動物も人間も家も全て潰すまでは転がってくるんだと
そうやってもう東西南北から転がって
あんたに一遍に来てくれるんだと
四人が走ってくる あんたどうするの？その場合
自分の方にこうやって転がってくるんだから
どうするの？あんたの場合
どうするんですかね その場合は
何かいいことをするしか方法はないんです
だから自分の命はもう諦める
逃げるとこないんだから
じゃあ北に逃げて 逃げられませんだから
北が山が転がってるんだ
北は危ない じゃあ南 南は危ない
じゃあ西 西は危ない じゃあ東
東は危ないんだから だから諦めるしかないんですね
諦めて死を待つしかないんです
その待つ時間はすごい長いでしょう
どうしようもない その間に何かいいことしなきゃいけないんだ
でお釈迦様があれはまあたとえなんですけど
実はそうなんです あんた方は瞬間瞬間年取っていくんだ
瞬間瞬間死を迎えていくんだと
瞬間瞬間いろんな嫌なものに危険なものでやってるんだから
老病死って言った そこにはもう攻撃されているんだけど
もうとっくに死ぬんだと
逃げ道がないんだと だからいいことをしなさいよ
で 結論出そうですね そこで王様を脅しちゃったんですね
いい加減にしてくださいと
ああだこうだとか悪ぼなあんた
あなたも他の人間も同じですと
たとえそんなこと言ったらお釈迦様殺されるかもしれませんでしょうに
僕みたいな人間だったら
そういう変なことを言って自分の首飛んじゃうかもしれませんだけど
お釈迦様だからよかったと思いますけどね
結局言ったのは あんた王であろうか
他の人間と何の変わりはないんだと
誰でも同じだと 死にかけているんだと
早く何とかしなさいと
早くいいことをしなさいということなんですね
大だからといって人を殺したりしてもしょうがない
政治ですよとか そんなもういいわけにならないよという厳しいことなんですけど
ものすごく美しく この心傷つけないように教えかけたんです
その知恵はどのように仏様に現れたかというと
ここら辺なんですね 物事を瞬間
瞬間 瞬間消えていく その恐怖感
その不異感はお釈迦様十分味わっていたんだから
なんのことなくそれを美しく一般人に翻訳して理解できるように言えた
ということで この恐怖
不異感 恐怖感 我々消えてく
消えてく 消えてく 消えてくという
その時に当然ながら あ
これは怖いと 逃げるどこもないと
だから逃げるどこあると怖くないんです
避難所があると 避難所ないから
それが怖い すごい恐怖感が生まれてくる
その時の知恵は何でしたっけ
カカンヒ カカンヒっていうのはアーディナワ・パッサナナーのアーディナワなんですけど
アーディナワっていうのはこの悪いことだけ見るということなんですね
アーディナワというのはディスアドバンテージということで
ものには長所 短所両方ありますね
短所だけ見えてしまうということなんですね
そこで物事を消えていくんだっていう
あの 壊滅地が生まれて
その上恐怖感も生まれてくる
それだったら当然ながらもういいこと一つもないんだ
これまた忘れていけない
これ自分の修行なんですね
だから自分のことを傷つけてるんだから
今まで一緒に生活した人々はみんな悪い連中ばっかり
いい人一人見なかったというふうな気持ちじゃないんです
自分のことだからすごい強烈なんです
何もいいことないという
気持ちが生まれてくるわけですね
そこら辺はこの瞬間に智慧が発達するんです
ゆっくりなのはこの 1番目ですね
観察能力なんですね それはゆっくりで
消滅能力もゆっくりなんですね
次にこの壊滅ですか 壊滅まではものすごく時間がかかる可能性あります
捨てる 捨てる そこら辺で人は大体瞑想をやめるんです
だからすごい根性が必要やと私は言ってるのはそういうことなんです
こんな強烈な心の変わることには
あのなんて言いますか
耐えられないと思いますけどね
だから弱い人にはできないんです
ヴィパッサナー 弱いんだったら最初からもう強い精神作っておかなくちゃいけないし
で 強さっていうのは知恵で生まれて
知識で生まれてくるんです
科学性で生まれてくるんです
だから昔は雷怖かったんだけど
今怖くないでしょうに
なぜ怖くないかというと
雷の働きを知ってるんだからなんです
だから恐怖感は強さを作るためには
知識 科学的な能力が必要なんですね
とにかく強い人にしかできないことなんですね
まあそこで あの一応壊滅のところに行ってしまえば
まあ瞬時にもう次の智慧っていうのはもうすぐすぐね
瞬時に生まれる場合もあります
やめなかったならば 大体は瞑想が抜けないですけど
そこら辺 やめるは逃げるはいろんなことが起こるんです
それでまああの大体この優しい指導者とかね
ちゃんと個人的につかまって指導する場合は大体わかります
まあそろそろ何時間かかるかと
何日ですかとかね この人は道場から逃げ出している時にいつですかとかね
まあ大体わかるんです
わかるんだったら まあ大体指導者っていうのは
まあその人そこら辺にまあ散歩をしたりとかね
あるいは自分もどこか歩き回って瞑想したりとかしているんです
だから先生に対してすっごい尊敬とかありますから
ああ 嫌だ もうやめた もう逃げるんだと思ってったっても
そこら辺に見えるんだからね
戻るんです でまあ大体もう三十分
一時間 二時間でその気持ちの消えて
次の一歩に智慧が生まれてきますからね
で 果敢のところからもうなんて言いますか
厭離というものが生まれてくる
もう執着が消えた もう執着することも何もなくなって
もうもう離れたいという
やめたいという 自分をやめたいということなんですね
何かやめたいではなくて
自分自身をやめたいという気持ちが生まれてくる
次に アーディーナ ニッビターナーナ ムンチット カンメターニャーナ
ニッビターっていうのはもう嫌われる
もういいやと もういわゆる希望が消えちゃうんですね
あれ 品物を捨てる前にもう
まあ嫌なものもういいっていう気持ちが出てくる
それから捨てる気持ちが生まれるんですね
それから脱する 解脱する気持ちがそこで初めて生まれてくる
そこまでの解脱したいっていうのは本当の気持ちじゃないんです
だから解脱したいなんていう気持ちっていうのは
ものすごいもう狂うほどの精神的なショック状態で生まれるものなんです
それほど簡単なものではない
だからこれ出世間の世界なんです
そこでも自分が全て消えてくことを感じて
もうそれでものすごい恐怖感感じて
それからもう もう短所ばっかり見えてしまって
まあそれから嫌になって
ああ じゃあ捨てましょうと
自分を捨てようという解脱する気持ちが生まれる
そこでまた落ち着く いや
解脱するんだと決めると
決めてまた物事を観察してて
そこであの深い あの濃かった感情の恐ろしさがずっと落ち着いてくるんですね
決めたんだから解脱するっていうことを
そこでまた観察始まるんです
その時の観察なんです
このパティサンパーナサッタっていうのは
それは何で処察支ですか
照察支っていう 同じこの一番目と同じなんです
サンマサニャーナと でもすごいレベルが高いんです
サンマサニャーナの場合は何も知らん人なんでしたけど
もうもう全て知ってる人なんです
全て知っていて 落ち着いて観察する
同じ観察能力なんですけど
レベル違う  [背景音楽]だからすべて知ってる人がものを見ると落ち着いてるでしょうに
何も知らない人はこれから観察するともう驚くわ
いろいろ感情が生まれてくるんです
だから落ち着いてる気持ちでまた観察してくちゃうんですね
そこでサンカーラウペッカーニャーナンというすべてのサンカーラについて
すべての物事についてウペッカー
まあ喜ぶこともなく 嫌わることもなく
まあウペッカーの気持ち
平安の気持ちが生まれてきて
そこでアヌローナニャーナンというのが生まれる
次にスヴィジュンチットというスヴィジュンチット
いわゆるすべてのサンカーラについて
現象について もうウペッカーの平安な気持ちが生まれたら
次にまあそれは解脱と無強烈な気持ち
もう何にもとらわれてない
何としても何もいても何を持ってるわけじゃない
感情持ってるわけじゃない
そのこの緩やかに水が流れて
例えば川に例えちゃうと
いろんなまあ曲がったりして
渦巻きを巻いたりして
滝になったり 暴流になったり
いろいろあって そこで平安の平らなうちにいたら
流れてるかいないかぐらいの落ち着いてくるような気持ちになってきて
その気持ちになってきたら
解脱の心が生まれるんです
そこはこの分間の出来事だから
そこら辺ですぐに気を付けてやるんです
そこはこのヴィパッサナーの修の段階なんですね
だからこのヴィパッサナー瞑想して何か体験するということじゃなくて
智慧が発達するということだから
だから瞑想にこのあなたはそこをどこまで行った
どこまで行ったという場合は
この智慧のレベルで言うんです
瞑想中お化け見たんだから
あんたはすごいですよとかね
言わないんで 感動したんだからすごいですよとも言わないんですね
智慧のレベルで見るんです
えーと まあそれでそれはあります
それから解脱も三種類に分かれています
スンニャというのとアニッというのとアッパマンというのと
それは日本語で空解脱・無常解脱・無願解脱
これはこの瞑想するとこの無常・空・無我という三つあります
この三つと言ったっても
本当は一つなんです 物事の本来の姿ですからね
一言葉で言ってもいいんです
でも 我々がわかりやすい目で見て
無常っていうのはわかりやすいし
もっと厳密に考えちゃうと
すべて空しいということで空もわかる
ちょっと難しいかもしれないけど
空で見ることのできる人
元気な人々 哲学的な人々は別に何か問題があって会社倒産したんだから出家に入ったわけじゃなくて
ただ若い時からこういうことをやりたかったんだっていうことでやってる人々にとっては
無我ということはもうわかるわけですね
そこで自分が発見した仮説のあれだ
証拠だからによって解脱にラベルをつけてるだけ
別に解脱は違う三つ解脱があるわけじゃないんです
そこでラベリングなんですけど
この空見えた人はアッパニという
じゃあ無常見えた人は無常解脱であって
苦見えた人 苦求が見えた人が無常解脱と言うし
無が見えた人の場合は苦解脱と言うんですね
順番逆になるだけ ですから
順番逆に置き換えてみてください
普通の順番というのは無常・苦・無我なんですね
解脱の場合は苦解脱・無常解脱・無願解脱
無常に苦解脱ではないんです
無我に苦解脱 お釈迦様に聞いた方がいいと思います
まだ解説は長く長い解説はありますけど
今日はできません で 次にヴィモッカムカ・解脱門
また同じことなんです